hello welcome back to the YouTube gaming
stage right here at PAX Prime I'm Donna
dwyer from gamespot it's my last
appointment of the day my last interview
and what a wonderful person to get to
talk to mr. Randy Pitchford sir how are
you doing hey man how's it going good to
see you are thanks I'll live in the
dream we are here my favorite show of
all yeah because this is super show
hacks exists with gamers yeah like you
got to eat three they don't even let
gamers in Oh press retailers this is
what video games and board gaming too
yeah passion vines I'm just super
psyched so you spend at least oh hey hey
go so you spend at least one day doing
actual work and then tomorrow is
predominantly you enjoying the fruits of
packed yourself right yeah yeah tomorrow
tomorrow is I have off pretty much I've
got a couple of like meetings but I'm
just gonna play all day tomorrow I end
up buying way too much stuff when I'm
here but yeah it's it's it's awesome to
be a packs a lot of cool games here yeah
at one of them of course battleborn you
guys have a massive boot dance day yes a
bunch of playable stations for people to
enjoy and what's it like actually
getting it in front of people whose a
game like this presumably requires a lot
of fun torturing and balancing so
watching people play must really well
super awesome to watch but you know
that's one of the things that I I think
we really thought about when we designed
and created battleborn was you know our
last game borderlands really requires a
huge time investment to get the most out
of it whereas battleborn is a hobby but
it's fun in the first five minutes and
we really wanted an accessible easy to
get into game and battleborn is that and
it's such a thrill I mean I feel bad
because the line is intense all right
you're like you know people are waiting
to in three hours to play the game and I
feel bad about that but it's so awesome
to be able to come here and introduce
people to the universe battleborn where
all of these factions are fighting over
the last star you know in the let you
can imagine at the end of the universe
when there's one star left what
happens to that star means everything
and there are all these different
creatures that have the capability of
traveling the stars and ending up at the
last stars they're all going to have
different opinions about what to do some
will want to protect it some will want
to study it and maybe like figure out
how to make more stars or make it last
longer and their disagreements will be a
profound because they're talking about
the end of the universe so the battle
for what how to handle this is probably
the biggest stakes ever and and the
heroes and champions that that do the
fighting these are the battle born and
that's what the game is all about you
guys must really love being able to
start with a fresh slate you like you've
done it so many times but like obviously
like packing when you started off doing
like half-life expansions but then like
all three brothers in arms and
borderlands was like this fresh like I
Peter you got to start off and enjoy so
is it nice going back to the start or
until I i know i think we exist to
entertain people and i think the future
is always more exciting than the past
and is in the challenge for us though is
we love the things we create right so
when we created the brothers and arms
franchise we went neck deep into that
like I was just living eating breathing
world war two history and tactical
gameplay and and I'm so I you know fell
in love with it and so it's neatest now
that we've created that we can attend to
it and we will be getting back to more
brothers in arms but if we only did that
for the rest of our careers that right
there would be no borderlands yeah right
so I remember when we were first talking
about borderlands and sharing it people
are like why are you doing that you
should be doing more brothers in arms
right and now we're creating battleborn
and there's a lot of folks it's like hey
make more borderlands and we will and we
love borderlands but I I think we
figured some things out and I think
we've learned some things and I think I
think battleborn is a better game and I
really hope that the people find it and
enjoy it because we're just we're having
a blast making it it's totally unique in
terms of when you especially when you
put it all together something I brothers
in arms and especially with borderlands
as well because that's a game that has a
loop which you know it lasts for hours
and hours and days and days this is a
much more sort of that it's like not
compacted into like a smaller segments
em but also there's a lot of these games
coming out now or like it seems like
this lot of similar goods I clipped
baczynski here earlier
that finally announced his gay and yeah
he was giving you [ __ ] about having a
mushroom man in the game as what he said
but like it that I'd like over watch the
games that like at least on first
appearance seemed like they have a lot
going on is that something that you are
similar things I love the fact that the
mana when overwatch was announced I
danced on the table for two reasons the
one that looks really cool but to you
know when we first started battle born
we were so off on her own there was
nothing at all that yeah i thought you
know and a lot of folks including myself
wondering are we crazy are people gonna
like this if blizzard shows up doing
something kind of similar it's like okay
maybe we're not completely nuts but but
let's be fair these are very different
games battleborn is a full-featured game
there is a campaign there's a story mode
you can play it so low you can play it
cooperative of course there's a PP a pvp
competitive mode where you can play it
against people in eSports capacity so we
do have that component but the other
thing is that it's launching as a
full-featured game that isn't trying to
be a free-to-play model yeah it's
launching you know you buy it and that
you have it you don't have to worry
about you know free-to-play kind of
thing going on here if you if you buy
battleborn you get the content that
comes with it of course you know if you
if you played borderlands you know that
that we like to do things in our
universe and our fans tend to bet beg
and demand anymore so it's almost
certain that will do dlc and add-ons for
battle born but if you're not into that
it's fine it's a complete game it's a
robust game and it's in and it's the
value of what's inside we've really
worked hard to make sure that there's
more value inside then then you know
what what it seems you would expect
further further for the price that the
games cost and we've been able to do
that because we're kind of betting that
we're going to reach a lot of people
yeah but we also did really well with
borderlands and so we're able to invest
a lot in the end borderlands launched
with four characters battleborn launches
with 25 characters and unlike
borderlands where you to experience the
full power of a character you need to
invest about 50 hours in battle born you
will experience the full growth curve of
a character within about you know within
that stat single scenario
campaign scenario or PvP scenario so
within that you know 20 to 40 minute
scenario you will get the maximum level
of that character and feel its full
power and capability and of course
there's customizations beyond that and
there's a metagame beyond that but if
you wanted to sample all of the
characters in the game and understand
what they're about you could do that in
about you know 12 or 15 hours yeah and
and that's awesome because there's so
much value in the experience the
characters I mean we're investing about
four times as much in each character
that we're developing for battle born
then we invested in each character we've
built for borderlands and a massive
spread of characters as well and indeed
one of the things when I think event
like the borderlands community which is
like this crazy that awesome here packs
to see so many like cosplayer there oh
they're amazing and for you guys who are
developing games for like a long period
of time like support the success of
Borderlands must have really changed the
way you guys approach like your
communities and development ike did you
there are aspects of olive or and it
looks like you guys have learned a lot
from the experience of making this game
which really captured a lot of people's
eyes I'd like to think we are getting
better at it I'd like to think that each
time we make games that we learn some
things and we apply those lessons to do
better but you know it is a dynamic
process and we also take risks and not
every risk we take everyone likes but
we're going to try and fight but I love
the community aspect in and we've always
been really engaged with our communities
even in our first game which was half
life opposing force long after the game
shift and not you know because we we
didn't even make any money doing it we
created half-life CTF half-life capture
the flag just because we wanted to
engage in a have fun and play the game
with our with the fans and people in the
community Borderlands of course created
a passionate fan base that is awesome
and insane and much larger than anything
I've ever experienced before and that of
course is how Borderlands grow up to new
levels and I can only hope that that
people respond as well to to battle born
and we're doing everything we can to try
to
you know give people reasons for
engaging with it but it's it's part of
the fun when it happens and i really i
really look forward to seeing what
unfolds yeah and i must be fun to see
people getting hands-on with it dance
there's oh man it's so great to you know
work so hard to build a thing and then
to be able to share it it's terrifying
me you know because you're gonna get
judged and everyone's tastes are
different but it's also very very
exciting and it's so nice to get
feedback and and this is a real audience
here at pax and we can kind of tell you
know when we come to pax it was a
turning point for borderlands 1 rating
yeah I mean up it up and even till the
e3 in the same year that the game
shipped and we'd been you know on the
road for two years with the game it was
really impossible to get attention for
it but we showed up two packs for the
first time with borderlands like a
couple months before shipped and the
love that we got and you know we there
were some awards that we got and just
but most of all just people wanted to
try it and they were waiting in line for
like sometimes 23 hours and then they
get in line again and that was just like
I thought man I think maybe we might
have something here I don't know so and
it's I can feel the energy here at pax
so I'm really hoping but you never know
i mean it's it's difficult the
entertainment is challenging hmm because
you know we all like things but we can't
be sure that the people we offer stuck
to you like things so we just do the
best we can and we hope we make some
people happy that's right weeks and if
people are here of course you can go
check out battleborn downstairs and also
want to talk to you a little bit of ADD
borderlines yeah I'm how is the tales of
the borderlands stuff oh it's so awesome
you know episode 4 just launched and
I've been warning people that love
borderlands since episode 2 that episode
4 was really going to mess with people
and you know sure enough everybody's
going nuts for some of the best reviews
I've ever seen telltale earn for any of
their games so I'm really proud of their
effort and I'm really excited about what
they've been doing with the franchise I
don't want to give any spoilers but if
you have not checked out tales from the
borderlands you definitely want to do it
i mean it is canonical and the final the
season finale episode 5 will be coming
up and tell tale we'll talk about it
soon but if you think episode 4 is a
melter you know I
I've read the script you know I was
involved in the outlining of the game
and i think it's i think it's going to
melt some faces man i think i think
episode 5 is really gonna is really
going to be meaningful to people that
let bordel answer do you think you're
going to do a second season of it I I
will see would like to I hope so I think
I think Telltale's doing amazing work
and I I hope that they have because I
think there's a couple things one do
fans want it and to to decree are the
creators passionate about it yeah and
three can we actually come up with
something that mate would make it worth
it if we build it do we have an eye we
have ideas that that will be a worthy
enterprise should we all go for it and
and we haven't answered those questions
yet but I hope the answer to all of
those questions is yes because I'm
having such a good time details for the
borderlands it's so fun to play these
games as a customer as opposed to oh
yeah correlators you know and so I
really want more Oh at last question
before I let you go in here I know
you've got a panel coming up in a little
while bit of news broke this morning and
something people have been hoping and
crossing their fingers / for a long time
you guys have locked down there is a
Borderlands movie in the works yeah
there was announcements this morning I
I'm actually going to be talking about
this in more detail today at 4pm in the
main theater at pat's pretty see you in
90 minutes yeah the the inside the
inside gearbox panel and if you go to
the gearbox website or the 2k website
and look around you'll probably find a
link where you can watch it live if
you're at home and it's going to start
and I got to get over there right after
this and we're going to go into some
details about that but that exists the
fact that there's that talent and know
that those people mean you're talking
about the Iraq that you know Ari and avi
arad and you're talking about lions gate
these are some of the greatest
filmmakers in the world and for them to
get involved that's not from us that's
from the fans the fans love borderlands
so much that they got behind it and and
how cool was it you know I was talking
earlier about how when we first started
talking about borderlands it was hard
for to get attention but some people
got it those early adopters are the ones
that kind of created that early momentum
how cool is it for those people that
noticed us at the beginning I was there
at the beginning and right now there's
people that can say that about
battleborn there's people that are
noticing battleborn right now and and
they're with us as we as we try to build
this thing and create this entirely new
crazy and same thing that is just
turning us on so much a gator box and
we're so thrilled and we're going to be
talking a lot about battleborn as well
in our man main theatre panel at 4pm my
name is Garrett packs check on our
website and gearbox software com and you
can see how to watch it all right save
your voice you got a lot of ya know it's
gonna be fun i'm gonna do a magic trick
too oh really yeah i should have asked
you to put all right now you choose
Rodney pitcher from gearbox off my
pleasure man thanks for having me not at
all a pleasure and thanks everyone for
watching yeah that's my bit done for
today actually but Chris waters coming
up we got a bunch more cool stuff coming
up right here on the YouTube gaming show
at PAX Prime so stick around with back
in a second